rocé bygmalion la sentence est tombée
c'est un coup de tonnerre nicolas
sarkozy condamné une nouvelle fois un an
de prison ferme pour nicolas sarkozy
reconnu coupable pour le financement
illégal de sa campagne présidentielle de
2012 le véritable bombe à qui
a mis les autres prévenus son ancien
directeur de campagne guillaume lambert
été condamné à trois ans et demi de
prison dont deux avec sursis et peine
considéré comme sévère par la défense le
président sarkozy n'a jamais demandé à
être mieux traité qu'un autre mais n'a
aucune raison de l'être moins bien son
avocat a laissé entendre que l'ancien
président de la république ferait appel
de ces décisions que jamais une
juridiction ne peut envisager une
sanction maximum lorsque le prévenu ce
qui est son cas aujourd'hui n'a jamais
été condamné en attendant nicolas
sarkozy contraint de porter un bracelet
électronique
alors est-ce une humiliation pour un
président
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
chez vous parce que c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable c'est le dos du jour laurent
seillier vous je sais plus d'être très
proche de nicolas sarkozy
on a vu sa réaction avoir actions déjà
sur les réseaux sociaux et la rage et
sur twitter nicolas sarkozy regardez ce
qu'il est mais là je veux remercier du
fond du coeur tous ceux qui ont tenu à
manifester leur amati leur amitié au mot
que j'ai été condamné pour avoir dépassé
le plafond de mes comptes de campagne
lors de la présidentielle de 2012 votre
soutien constant fidèles courageux me
donne la force pour poursuivre ce combat
si nécessaire pour la vérité pour la
justice je demande simplement que le
droit soit appliqué pour moi comme pour
n'importe quel autre judiciaire vu les
justiciables or celui ci a été une
nouvelle fois bafouée par la
méconnaissance des décisions du conseil
constitutionnel
merci
ça l'énervé vite
à seulement bravo aux équipes alors
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
interjeté l'appel j'ai interrogé j'ai
interjeté l'appel afin que la cour dise
le droit j'irai jusqu'au bout dans cette
quête qui dépasse mon cas personnel car
chacun peut un jour se trouvait
confortée à l'injustice pour foncer la
certitude de la justesse de ce combat
qu'il me donne l'énergie qui permet de
surmonter des épreuves et de résister
aux vaine tentative d'humiliation mois
il parle d'humiliation ben nicholas
ainsi je serais heureux de vous
retrouver ce samedi à paris à 11 heures
à la librairie lamartine merci merci
merci nicolas sarkozy qu'est ce que vous
dites laurent ça y est je sais que vous
êtes très touché par cette décision et
vous êtes nombreux à être touchés voilà
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un ancien
président est le symbole est fort oui
puis c'était une injustice parce que qui
peut penser que nicolas sarkozy alors
que l'été est président de la république
et candidat pouvait regarder le détail
de ses comptes de campagne c'est
incompréhensible
oui c'est une décision qui est fait pour
l'humilier est ce que vous pouvez
imaginer le président sarkozy avec un
bracelet électronique pas moi parce que
je leur tends
exactement qu'il est présumé innocent un
dommage pour tous ceux qui s en
réjouissent mais évidemment qu'il va
continuer le combat et je ne doute pas
qu'il va réussir à prouver son innocence
ça vous choque ça vous choque cette
décision ça me choque de peut-être
pouvoir voir l'ancien président avec un
bracelet électronique ça m'a glacé en
fait vraiment oui je suis écoeuré c'est
ce que je lui ai écrit que j'étais glacé
en fait ça m'a jetée stupéfaite dégoûté
en fait c'est incompréhensible vous
rendez compte 20 qui peut imaginer vous
savez ce que c'est être présent de la
république non banon
que moi encore non dans ses terres en
lien avec votre article magnifique
lecture que je recommande à tout le
monde bien sûr c'est un petit revenir
sérieusement aux sujets qu'ils aient
vraiment dingue alors quand je vois le
déferlement de haine de certains qui
effectivement se réjouissent de ça mais
où va la france comment peut-on être
dans cette position de se réjouir de
voir l'ancien truand la république
condamné et qui plus est pour des faits
que personne ne peut croire qu'ils sont
réels alors on à alexis qui est pas du
tout d'accord avec vous un éditorialiste
rt france d'alexis qui va nous dire son
point de vue dans un instant qu'ils
veulent et sont pas du juste vous autour
de la table je vais prendre un hot
wheels géraldine maillet vous vous êtes
vous êtes communes rance ça y est pas
pour non pas du tout en fait moi que
c'est mignon pour lui mais c'est aussi
humiliant pour nous les français en fait
et je vois pas pourquoi vous dites qu'il
n'a rien fait puisqu'il a été jugé donc
même si elle présente son innocence
parce qu'il fait appel d'ailleurs la
plupart des autres dans cette affaire ne
font pas appel parce que celle
finalement ça prouve que sans doute ils
se sentent coupables moi je trouve que
c'est très bien qu'ils soient traités
comme les autres on est citoyen je
sauve été question de les coacher
géraldine que j'adore françois hollande
jean toujours chez vous
c'est quoi c'est bien comme les esclaves
icolas sarkozy a déjà dîné chez vous non
françois hollande oui
c'est pas comme les autres est ce que
jamais quand on n'a jamais été condamné
parce qu'il n'a pas été condamné une
première fois la barre des procès est ce
que c'est vrai coupable s'il vous plaît
cette première installation donc
considérons que comme c'est un
justiciable comme les autres
pour sa première condamnation du mois de
mars considérons qu'il est innocent
d'une part je pense que ça vous pouvez
le concevoir dont faisait ensuite
justice à géométrie variable
évidemment quand les réquisitions du
procureur sont de 6 mois avec sursis et
6 mois ferme et vous prenez un an ferme
est-ce que c'est pas une décision qui
est injuste ou qui est à l'excès de ce
qu'on pourrait faire un justiciable
comme un autre mais vous pensez bien
lors jure la même chose ça y est est ce
que vous auriez été aussi choqué savait
était françois hollande je ne connais
pas françois hollande n'a donc je ne
sais pas de quoi il est capable ce que
je sais c'est que nicolas sarkozy ne va
pas trafiqué ses comptes de campagne
volontairement non pas tant parce que
s'il paraît déjà
je dis ça avec ses dunes voilà une
information à prendre avec des pincettes
sont paraît-il que françois hollande a
volé des pimms adore la côte
mais il n'y a qu'une chose qui sera
aberrante vraiment c'est que je ne dis
pas qu'il a trafiqué les comptes enfin
s'il a des yeux y en a un qui faisait
une campagne à la trump c'était
gigantesques et des écrans et l'autre
dans une fête de village en province où
il y avait hollande
c'est impossible je n'ai pas vu de sa
campagne était dépassé les plafonds en
revanche l'éloge en juin dernier
effectivement c'est que encore une fois
le pays qui passent pour des charlots
dans le monde entier et nous c'est nous
encore une fois ses nouveaux-nés à nancy
après les dents il a quand même violé
personne pour l'instant on dit juste que
si le trafic d'argent ou de ces mâles
n'ont pas ces américains gens traités
en faisant ça eh ben voilà donc c'est
encore pire qu'on salue marie jeanne
benameur it pas laisser le sentiment
d'avoir un bracelet et conçoit la honte
du monde entier une fois encore au pied
ou à la maison de quartier avec un
président car brest est franchement
injuste dans cette affaire il a déjà été
jugé ce qui l'a rendu l'argent ab oui
allez le sarkothon oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai ce que c'est vrai au fait le
conseil constitutionnel lui ai demandé
de rendre les excédents de campagne et
ce qu'il a fait et elle était jugée donc
en fait en france on peut pas être jugé
deux fois pour les mêmes causes donc sur
ce fait là je pense que pour le coup
pour le coup il va très vite se sont
illustrés sur le détail qu'on n'a pas
dit c'est que quand s'il avait été élu
il aurait pu être inéligibles ou être
mais ça a le mérite souhaite plus être
remise en cause est ce que vous pensez
sérieusement que vous allez prendre le
risque quand vous faites votre campagne
d'être invalidée en trafiquant des
comptes de campagne mais qui peut penser
un truc pareil être président de la
république c'est le c'est toute une vie
vous pensez que vous allez vous mettre
en danger un trafiquant vos comptes de
campagne c'est invraisemblable ça me
semble curieux aussi alors allez poussin
alexis poule moi je pense qu'on va pas
refaire le travail de la justice ici sur
ce plateau c'est pas le lieu on m'a pas
être avocat procureur ou le juge s'est
compliquée avec la cia
[Rires]
l'hermine de nantes et l'histoire on est
loin du compte douze affaires pour
lesquelles nicolas sarkozy a été
impliqué deux condamnations alors certes
c'est pour la même chose et il va faire
appel et encore le dossier libyen qui
n'est pas juger une pièce de théâtre
d'ailleurs le 22 et le 23 octobre
alfortville l'homme qui devait marquer
d'affi pour parler de ce financement si
j'ai un gamin de 20 ans j'en profite oui
oui
ça s'appelle promenade donc très bien
bas avec plaisir et il ya quelque chose
quand même dans la gestion des affaires
de l'ump pas forcément celle de nicolas
sarkozy mais ce pygmalion c'est
scandaleux c'est un scandale et que
l'ancien président n'ait rien vu c'est
sa défense mais la justice est en train
de faire son travail il a fait appel et
heureusement et jusqu'au preuve du
contraire on le sent et on verra ce qui
se passe mais quand même ça fait
beaucoup 12 à faire pour un ancien
président et je trouve que au contraire
le fait que l'on mette un bracelet à un
ancien président c'est pas grave c'est
pas une humiliation pour le pays après
veut dire que la démocratie fonctionne
ça veut dire qu'on n'est que justice qui
marche ça veut dire qu'on peut juger des
chefs d'état dans ce pays il ya des pays
où on peut pas le faire donc c'est quand
même pas mal de pouvoir le faire dans
notre pays de dire que oui nicolas
sarkozy est un justiciable comme un
autre et effectivement il n'y a pas de
justice d'exception et politique c'est
pas évident politique je tenais vraiment
à l'analyse des dd fait c'est parce que
vous n'aimez incognito mois de procès
n'aimait pas sarkozy vous n'aimez pas
macropolitique
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas crédible
pour en parler le bio c'est une supporte
ni en mémoire ou madoff
[Musique]
on
sait d'où je viens mais vous vous
présentez comme si vous pouviez analyses
traditionnelles ont fait une pièce de
théâtre alors qu'en fait connaître qu'un
acteur politique contre lui au plus tôt
je fais du temps les radicaux lâche
qu'est ce que je dis je dis simplement
que l'on n'est pas sur un plateau pour
dire c'est assez injuste c'est honteux
il y va en tout cas qui ne sont pas dans
un combat politique oui mais vous non
alors que valérie benaïm
présent c'est parce qu'effectivement la
une cour de justice en mai mais il fait
appel donc tout va bien non c'est bien
qu'on montre effectivement qu'un homme
aussi puissant soit-il peut être un
justiciable comme un autre exactement
autant pour autant on peut s'interroger
quand même puisque le parc est enfin on
est allé au-delà des réquisitions du
parquet c'est à dire qu'effectivement il
demandait six mois avec sursis là il
prend un an ferme plus un bracelet
électronique qui n'avait pas été réclamé
c'est dire qu'on demande à un président
de la république de rester à domicile a
signé chez lui et par ailleurs quand on
lit les rituels la présidente du
tribunal il ya une leçon de morale qui
est fait à nicolas sarkozy donc elle
outrepasse les droits de deux des scuds
vrai qu'à part qui était flottant
du coup il ya voulons il ya quelque
chose qui cloche un tel acte est aussi
que c'est un procès où la morale est
important que la vertu est important à
président la république c'est le garant
des institutions
voir qu'il est devant la justice sur 12
à faire évidemment qui est un problème
évidemment qui est un problème dont et
on doit parler et au delà de bien sûr
des camps partisans et au delà de toutes
les chaînes ont pensé ça m'est égal
alexis poulain lui ai dit tu auras liste
rt france pense qu'il doit être logé à
la même enseigne que tout le monde et
que pour lui pense que voilà c'est passé
c'est pas complètement c'est à la même
enseigne ces prix plus que les autres
c'est ça c'est bon vous dites vous et
c'est 7 centimes en tous cas pas mal de
gens disent que voilà c'est ça tout à
fait c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
exceptionnel que pour une première
condamnation je leur dis bien que c'est
une première condamnation on est au
maximum de la peine est encore plus
exceptionnel qu'on aille au delà des
réquisitions du procureur donc c'est une
sanction qui va bien au-delà de ce qui
serait mérité s'il était coupable ce que
je ne pense pas moi pour ma part en tout
cas parce que comme je le disais tout à
l'heure je n'imagine pas connaissant la
passion nicolas sarkozy pour son
engagement et pour la france qu'il
puisse ne serait-ce que mettre en cause
ou mettre en risque sa réélection son
second mandat en trafiquant des comptes
de campagne j'invite chacun à
s'intéresser à ce qu'est une campagne
électorale à voir comment on fait une
campagne concrètement les déplacements
d'un candidat à voir la machine énorme
que qui existent pour faire mettre en
place une campagne non vous savez par
messieurs puisque nous la baie
de la canche et de billy inquiétudes en
ciel libyen il ya déjà eu qu'à
finir
faire une campagne en étant président de
la république pour ceux qui peuvent
avoir la naïveté de penser qu'on peut
tous les soirs regarder ses comptes et
compter les chefs des meetings ou de
regarder aux médias de spots là je pense
qu on est dans un délire complet alors
j'ai appelé e juste bernard montiel vous
vous trouvez que c'est humiliant ah bah
oui complètement moi aussi j'étais très
surpris par cette décision et comme le
dit très bien laurent ça y est c'est
vrai que ça a été au delà du raid et des
réquisitions de sac est hallucinant dit
on dit je vous dis moi je vous dit où
les on-dit 1 on dit qu'on a sanctionné
nicolas sarkozy parce que on voulait pas
qu'il se représente qui reviennent dans
le jeu politique est ce que c'est une
hypothèse qui est
je pense que si vous voulez de toute
façon nicolas sarkozy n'avait pas décidé
d'aller à la présidentielle
oui mais imaginons oui monde ici on se
prépare aux primes est un danger alors
trouvez vous en dirai plus tard je
trouve que du ferrain pendant 10-15
dernières primaires il n'avait pas voulu
mais il l'avait jamais reçu que françois
hollande
vous avez compris mon avis sur la
décision de la décision de justice
autant je veux pas rentrer dans d'autres
interprétations qui serait politique je
pense que justement déjà ça dessert à
'b-' le président sarkozy que d'aller
dans les délires de complotisme d'accord
qui qui sont que j'ai entendu aussi
effectivement non non je pense qu'il
faut en rester aux faits et à la peine
prononcée par rapport à ce qui a été
demandé vraiment ce qu'ils disent non
aux rimes doivent d'abord moi je dis non
parce que je trouve pas je trouve pas
que ce soit et millions une chose moi en
tant que président j'aimais bien ce
qu'il avait fait sur la crise de 2008 on
avait limité la casse quand nos voisins
s'étaient cassé la gueule donc ça c'est
dit ensuite je vois pas je n'arrive pas
à comprendre pourquoi tous racontent non
mais mon avis écrits d'amour en 2008
continuer à clouer bien aimé comment il
avait géré cette crise gérée mots à
l'epo maintenant je ne vois pas je ne
vois pas en quoi ils sont tous en train
de dire les hommes politiques on veut
être proche des français on veut être
comme les français on ressemble aux
français à partir donc tpu président
cette enquête bygmalion ça dure combien
de temps 10 ans ça dure et que
maintenant 10 ou au bout de 10 ans et
pas une enquête de 1 mois et j'ai
remarqué que à chaque fois voulait pas
que les hommes politiques aillent en
prison et voulait pas qu'ils soient
jugés donc si c'est des présidents si
c'est des premiers ministres à ce moment
là ils me font les plus grosses
conneries du monde et ils vont pas en
prison que ce soit les fab us les
cahuzac les benalla les filles ont les
balkany cela ils ont pas droit d'aller
en prison sous prétexte de cette semaine
est
camille aubert attendant la sortie parce
qu'ils la marijuana
[Applaudissements]
whittier
groupe ce qui me gêne c'est que j'ai la
pression des états unis en 2008 j'ai
bien aimé en 2008 à des gemmes pape les
épaules et la table d'accord mais amène
en mer au monde un petit groupe ne soyez
pas comme ça à dire vous pas qu'ils
aillent en prison c'est rien car dit-il
et qui c'est qui va le contrôle et saint
louis qui a dit ça vous voyez un
policier les contrôles et sarkozy pour
l'indien sur ces outils là dessus
c'est sûr c'est automatique oui c'est
comme les tic dans votre vie c'est
normal c'est que j'ai l'impression quand
on vous écoute que parce que c'est
nicolas sarkozy et parce que c'est un
ancien président quoi qu'il fasse il a
une espèce d'immunité avis est qu'il est
au dessus des lois et moi en fait je
pense que la perception que plein de
gens font ça fait des mois qu'on entend
que nicolas sarkozy doit aller en prison
alors on sait c'est la loi française il
ira jamais en prison vraiment réellement
il fera pas de prison ferme mais même le
bracelet électronique lampard du brass
et il va faire appel il va pas forcément
porter le bracelet mais je pense que ça
envoie un signal que les hommes
politiques et les anciens présidents ont
cette espèce d'immunité avis et sont au
dessus des lois alors vraiment pas
d'immunité est par contre je répond
d'abord avec le choeur avec l'émotion
parce que c'est un ami donc évidemment
il ne cache pas
[Musique]
un ami qui subit quelque chose d
difficile vous êtes touchés et dans
l'émotion
j'espère que chacun aurait la même eu la
même réaction sinon je préfère c'est
donc évident que ma parole ne vaut rien
mais
à visage découvert moi je suis pas un
truc cacher mais
j'suis connaissez mais on connaissait on
connaît le fonctionnement va voir ce que
pensent ses téléspectateurs s'il vous
plaît voilà oui 52 pour son nom à carros
et 17 janvier à celle au mieux quand
même qu'ils l'emportent mais de très peu